you
so mr. secretary Peter England I would
first of all like to congratulate you on
what I think is going to be a very
popular price yes
I hope so Alice Monroe she's in her
eighties now and she has written
exclusively short stories as far as you
understand yes well she written one book
it's a collection of stories regarding
the same dealing with the same people
and she has also written one of my
personal favorites is a a book she wrote
I think it came out 2006 which is called
the view from Castle Rock which is sort
of of it hybrid between a history fact
and fiction where she investigates her
own family background going back to to
Scotland and so on and I don't know what
you call that one but besides these two
once she has only written the short
stories yes I read it now and then over
the years and you are structures I'm
struck by the fact that she moves in a
rather small world it's Canadian it's
that the back backwater towns and so on
could you say something about Amelia oh
yes oh yes Shh it is almost exclusively
what happens almost exclusively it takes
place its southwestern Ontario is on the
edge of some software job of Canada is a
very flat rural area with broad rivers
in small towns and that's that's her EU
there that's where she finds her subject
and where she finds her people then once
in a while she she can go out and do
something very much else because she has
she's really a blue orphan but I think
she has everything she needs in this
small patch of work that that is her new
capital in our county
and one of the words you find when you
read reviews of your books is the word
ambiguity that is she's fascinated by
the sort of sliding feeling between
people and psychology that it's put on
its head can you comment a little bit on
that well I think she is is very good at
capturing these different modes in
people not feeling you know a bit
sitting on the fence I think no one has
better deconstructed the central model
myth of romantic love not just saying
that it means they so it means that but
showing that people can very very few
very very different things about about
it there is a quotation from one more
short stories yeah it was a miracle it
was a mistake it was what she dreamed of
it was not what she wanted and having
this ability to pick out decent people
not knowing exactly how they should
react and so on she is a fantastic
portrayal of human beings small people
big feelings as they say yes just one
more question
she's now in her 80s and she said that
she is going to stop writing yeah do we
have any comment on that
ah I don't know she has you should know
she has written since the early 50s
trouble writing because the first 10 20
years she was a home housewives helping
her Hospital working with the business
and so on and she has done a really
marvelous job what she has done is quite
enough it's quite enough to get to the
belfry so if she wants to stop writing
that's her own that's her own decision
office there was a small book published
called the real life or a dear life it's
your life July yes and in it there is a
tool sort of an autobiography in the end
which is very interesting a couple of
also by our biographical text it gives
number of clues
to the the entire so thank you again
then and communications on a very very
popular price I think